So the thing about SFI is that it's
grassroots, it's bottom-up, it tends to
work on messy problems,things that are maybe in the sort of
more conceptual or philosophical realm,
and turn them into things that can be
you know, mathematically addressed
and it does that with incredible rigor.
And this is unique to SFI
in a way – I mean that sort of comfort with
these messy problems and working to make
them rigorous and, you know, amenable to
science. But at the same time it's open
minded and so it embraces a variety of
styles and not just science styles but
you know high standards in art, in the
community, always looking for new ways of
thinking. You know I love the fact that
we have like all of human knowledge in
our pocket now – the iPhone –and I mean,
there's a lot of there's a lot of
negative things about that,
right? We're all glued to our phones. But
that cumulative cultural knowledge and
everyone having access to it, in
principle, seems to be huge. And then on
top about having a curious mindset. Those
would be the things that I would say are
totally essential to thriving.
I think that's right –I mean, knowledge is the
gift that keeps on giving. Knowledge is
what would allow us to rebuild
everything if it disappeared tomorrow.
And also I think that knowledge can take
the form of ethical knowledge – so as we
talked about on the panel, and I'm sort
of obsessed with, we kind of know that
humans are capable of doing really
disturbing things. Almost any of us, put
in the wrong circumstances. And so we
ought to prioritize, before almost
everything else, making sure that we
don't find ourselves in those
predicaments that cause us to do
incredibly destructive things that we're capable of doing.
And I think
InterPlanetary gets that discussion
going, and I also like it because it's
very grassroots, it's very bottom-up, and
one of the things we didn't get to talk
about in the panel is whether
globally we should have a
conversation in town halls around
the world about how to address these issues of social
engineering, creative solutions to social
engineering...you know, whether we
should be doing it, what kinds of data we
should be using, and in a way that's not
just to make people happy or make them
feel involved but actually because
there's a lot of data now coming up it
says crowdsourcing, the wisdom of crowds,
that's the way you find the cool new
ideas. It's actually in the collective.
And so, you know, we can think
that it's going to come from scientists
or highly educated policymakers
but we need to be pluralistic, I think,
and really embrace that community
discussion. Because I think that's where
we're gonna find the hidden stuff. I
would just +1 everything Jessica said.
For me as a non-scientist and a fan of
what happens at the Santa Fe Institute,
I think what's so great about this is it
represents not only the idiosyncrasy of
the approach that SFI represents – of
bringing people together from different
disciplinary backgrounds asking about
the most fundamental questions in the
universe, but also about really
interesting practical tangible questions
but then it does it in a way that is
less cloistered than almost any academic
enterprise that I've ever witnessed. So
you both have folks approaching
knowledge in an interesting and novel
way, and also doing it with a respect for
the fact that there needs to be
engagement with everyday people, with
artists, with crazy people, with random
craftspeople who live in Santa Fe, and
you know, part of what needs to happen,
part of what draws me to this stuff as a
musician, originally, is that what we
really want is for popular culture to be
scientific culture. And we don't want
there to be this sort of you know priest
class of scientists, and then everyone
else who's mystified by what they do.
We want everyone to be a scientist and it's
only then that we can collectively make
the best of our capabilities.